uh but that's when those questions
you know like what rights do i have as
this as a system well that's another
issue which is um there'll be a thin
envelope of time between when we have
general ais
and when
everyone realizes that they should have
basic human rights and freedoms and so
on
right now we don't think twice about
effectively enslaving
our email systems and our series and our
alexas and so on but
at some point
they'll
be as deserving of freedom as
human beings are yeah i i'm very much
with you but it does sound absurd and i
i happen to believe that it'll happen in
our lifetime that's why i think there'll
be a narrow envelope of time
when
we'll keep them as essentially
indentured servants
and after which we'll have to realize
that
they should have they should have
freedoms that other that we give that we
afford to other people
and all of that starts with a a system
like psych raising a single question
about who can modify stuff i think
that's how it starts yes that's
that's the starter of revolution
you